in South Africa's governing African
National Congress is holding its final
campaign rally ahead of a general
election supporters poured into the
Johannesburg stadium for the event it's
aimed at boosting support for the party
as it faces the strongest challenge
challenge yet to its 25 years in power
president cyril ramaphosa is promising
new jobs and economic growth the ANC has
governed South Africa since the racist
apartheid system ended but has been
shaken by several corruption scandals
joining me live from that rally in
Johannesburg is DW is Christine mundo
Christine hi
the ANC has been in power since 94 when
Nelson Mandela became president what's
at stake for the party in this election
Rebecca as you rightly said this is the
most contested election in South
Africa's history poster party there is
the ANC has enjoyed big majority wins
when it comes to the polls but in the
last two elections support has been
sliding what the new leadership of
African National Congress is looking to
do led by cyril ramaphosa is to reverse
those losses at the polls you now have
another player on the scene that is the
economic freedom fighters taking away
young people from this party young
people who are frustrated that the
African National Congress has not done
enough to change their lives 25 years
into this democracy Rebecca as you say
support has been dropping for the party
Cyril Ramaphosa trying to restore some
of that image of the ANC how successful
has he been so far
Rebecca and that's what this elections
really going to tell us the result that
the ANC gets is going to be telling how
much the Ramah poster effect or AMA for
years it's been left here in South
Africa it's going to translate into
getting those despondent apathetic
voters back to the polls a lot of people
had walked away from the party people
who part necessarily vote for another
party but had decided that they wouldn't
be voting at all rom opposes message to
a and C supporters has been that the
party has reformed its rebranded that
they've looked at the past and they've
seen the mistakes that they've made
neglecting the people corruption that
has taken place in this country he is
saying to South Africans that with his
presidency things are going to change he
spoke today about job creation Rebecca
he spoke today about not letting another
generation of South Africans be destined
for poverty the stakes are high and a
lot is hinging on drama poses image of a
clean man who is not corrupt to come in
and change the face of this party
Rebecca part of the reason why Jacob
Zuma could not finish a term that was
meant to finish now it's because the ANC
needed to change face by the time this
election comes so drama poster has been
in office for just over a year and the
message to South Africans has been I'm
gonna bring back investments because
people trust me and that is gonna
translate into job creation especially
for young people Rebecca were talking
about a country with unemployment north
of 25 percent the bulk of that are young
people in this country corruption has
seen investment flow out of fear and so
when lot is at stake for the African
National Congress it has to prove that
it is still relevant for South Africa 25
years post apartheid so job creation and
the economy would you say that's the
most pressing issue that is that what
voters want the next government to
address
that is essentially if Rebecca you've
got a lot of South Africans living in in
poverty we talk about poverty being less
than a dollar a day a lot of South
Africans living far below that young
people are unemployed and in fact the
Electoral Commission talked about the
fact that a bump of those people
qualified to vote who aren't doing so
are young people and a lot of them say
I've been speaking to some of them that
they don't feel like the politicians
have done anything for them and will be
doing so any time so jobs I mean this is
one of the most unequal societies in the
world according to Gini coefficient so
you're talking about a country that is
plagued with poverty there has been one
of the ticking time bombs that have been
warned by forecasters all over the world
the likes of the IMF and the World Bank
the unemployment rate sure is far too
high a lot of young people not doing
anything and so that is the key thing
Rebekah addressing the issue of jobs
bringing back investment into this
economy
Christine moon were in Johannesburg
thanks very much for that update